obviously the big story this week is the
prisoner swap we got back
sergeant Bowl berdahl from Afghanistan
in exchange for five Taliban prisoners
from Guantanamo Bay
there is all kinda stuff going on that
by the time we post this will probably
change
there's some question as to whether sick
soldiers actually died while looking for
him he may have been a deserter and had
not been captured actually
all kinda stuff but i wanna talk about
this a jeffrey toobin on CNN he is their
legal analyst I often don't agree with
him on a lot of stuff
usually that the NSA but he's saying
that President Obama
actually broke the law by not going to
congress before
a authorizing the prisoner release let's
take a look
you look at the law you look at the
signing statement you've gone through it
did the president break the law by your
engaging in this deal
no I think he clearly worked a lot be
the law says 30 days notice
he didn't give 30 days notice now it is
true that he issued a signing statement
but signing statements are not lost
signing statements are the president's
opinion
about what the law should mean
now it may be that the laws
unconstitutional a violation of his
power powers commander chief
but no court has held that the law is on
the books
and he didn't follow well as well as far
as I know we thought something all the
constitution in this country even if we
don't pay that much attention to it
so yet he had a signing statement but
that doesn't supersede the law
so that's what I want to talk about here
at does anyone care
about the law in effect yet like are we
still surprised that Obama broke the law
I mean what about
ordering a a drone strike on american
for little doubt due process in secret
what about the unprofor president warned
whistleblowers what about spying on the
American people the NSA
accounting dead military aged males
killed by drone strike that combatants
our site imeem
into law the in training up the
executive power
to indefinitely detain terror suspects
without trial
really worth the price get so well don't
give you took care for my whole point
yeah
sorry yeah that was perfect that was
provided that was my point that
we've done so much of this other excuse
that I me know if you're not surprised
but I don't need excuses that
I'm anything in this particular case
does really matter to congress got
approval
heavily not really because there would
probably agree with that anyway
so this particular his I don't really
think it matters I think the bigger
issue is that this keeps happening
and it's sad that we're not surprised
about it yes so President Obama did
issue
statement about this we have consulted
with congress for quite some time about
the possibility that we might need to
execute a prisoner exchange in order to
recover sergeant bird I'll
we saw an opportunity we were concerned
about sargent Bergdahl's help
we had the cooperation up Qataris to
execute exchanger we seize that
opportunity
and the process was truncated because we
wanted to make sure that we did not miss
that window
now what they are also saying is that
Bergdahl had some health issues
now he's being checked right now but it
no one knows where he is exactly so we
haven't been able to verify that there
was some sorta
health issue that made this a you know
that they needed to have this happen
immediately
so even that statement like I get it
like he's like where we wanted to make
this happen wanna make a quick a
tentative
but again that doesn't super see the law
so should anyone
should we do anything about this it is I
think this is the type thing with the
media just gonna drop
and I think I broke the law again
depleted a I think because it made
strategic sense we're not that upset
about it right
on but and I think the major issue is
that
the keeper he keeps breaking the law
this administration the former
administration keeps breaking the law
and a lot and it doesn't make sense and
we don't get an explanation
so I think bill that if we had more
trust in the government and stuff like
this would be more possible i think im
just really upset because this is just
another example
how the law is not followed and how we
are not given
information on at all you mentioned so
many things that although nothing
lol forgot about so all those things
when you add up all those things are
those
how do you think we're gonna look back
at the Obama presidency
especially when it comes to be sort of
security issues and the spying in all
that like he really
in my opinion he's has has severely
dropped the ball here
well yeah but were sorta used to him
dropping the ball
but in this case I feel like we didn't
know so little about
a Bergdahl you know well
with the deserter ready sick how many
people died looking for him
where is he now they're so that such a
lack of transparency that are equal
will remember for a long time would any
of that change your opinion on it if it
turned out that he was really sick and
they knew he had two weeks to live with
that
then mitigate you say well okay he can
go ahead a break books we want him back
for you guys I at the again I think in
this particular situation I'm not part
I'm not upset about the strategic yeah
in a move that was taken and they broke
the law because the law other men sort
of a safeguard their mentally guy do you
think what I can be broken
yeah I meant to be broken he has
something they don't make sense
I'm but but issue is that these laws
keep being broken when that we don't
have any information or any transparency
as you mentioned as to why it makes
sense to break the law
yeah do you think the mainstream media
might be more upset about this
if it was say president bush well you
have to remember that present their
precious president reagan
them a little actually far worse for
weapons to Iran
yeah and it was a huge failure and we
kinda forgot about that isn't he the
Messiah
love the Republican Party no right and
also people were saying well we don't
negotiate with terrorists that read that
yet another a run that began serving
throw thing right now
except we done with the path in this was
in negotiations with the prisoner swap
which is different than negotiating with
Terry NASA
it's all right for everybody but it's
not exactly it may their
their get that so that's a whole other
topic but for this story is going to
just keep going on and I'm sure we'll
cover
more but next week